Luke Cage I'm looking for has anybody
seen location I swear this was his party
but like I keep only catching fleeting
glimpses of him so Luke 8 season 2 I
have finished it and I don't entirely
know how to assess this I personally am
disappointed having finished off the
second season however I can't say that
what I don't like about it is actually
necessarily bad and this is another one
of those cases where I've slept on and
kind of spent the last 24 hours or so
thinking and rethinking this through
trying to justify you know my feelings I
mean going maybe I can't or at least not
fully so if you couldn't guess from my
sort of opening joke there my big issue
with this is doesn't really seem to be
about Luke Cage like very much at all he
he he feels as much the main character
of this as Bilbo Baggins did of the
Hobbit trilogy of films so and I to a
certain extent I almost feel like the
show knows this because I give spoilers
just let me say that now because like
later on towards the end they had like
Mariah and other characters talked to
him like this all started with you this
whole thing is your fault that I'm
looking at that you're looking at the
screen going no it's not because what's
moving the plot is this vendetta that
bushmaster has against the Stokes family
that he's taking out on Mariah
specifically Luke Cage didn't instigate
that arguably luke cage's presence you
know is why cottonmouths not currently
in power but you know because trying to
take out Luke was what kind of got him
unstable and led to a lot of what
happened in the first season but
bushmasters lucky because cottonmouths
gone
masters here to take out a vendetta TIFF
cottonmouths was here he'd still be
doing it he just be taking on both him
and Mariah instead of just Mariah so the
the the show trying to justify Luke's
name being the title game across is
really weak so I mean seriously how much
does Luke actually impact this plot he
impacts a couple of key points he does
rescue Mariah once but it's something
that he stumbles into he teams up with
bushmaster but I get the feeling that
bushmaster considering that he was saved
by Mariah's daughter by Tilda that Luke
wasn't even gonna be necessary for him
Forbush must to be able to do his thing
Luke just kind of like held him back a
little like the whole the whole thing it
feels like they tried I don't see I've
never seen an empire but it feels like
they were trying to like mashup Empire
and like Game of Thrones like the
Lannisters or something and and we and
make it this big ensemble thing which in
and of itself isn't a horrible story to
tell just not Luke Cage and I'm not
saying you can't have a strong
supporting cast and like all this other
stuff going on but Luke needed to be
either the focus of more characters or
the primary driver of the plot and he
was neither he was more just a thorn in
the side of both Mariah and Bushmaster
and or an ally to them briefly at
various points neither of these
villainous characters our actually truly
focused on Luke a she's just kind of
there and Luke is not the primary plot
mover like as I said he comes and he
does a couple of key things but he's
pulling supporting role wait at best but
having said that as I as I mentioned
it's not a bad story of familial
venj and you know sins of the past
coming back to haunt and things like
that it's fairly decently done so if
you're with if you're willing and you're
prepared to make that shift and accept
that Luke is not actually the main
character of this then it's pretty good
but like for me that's that's something
that I couldn't get over because I
really like mike colter in this part and
it's funny somebody actually commented
on my last video reviewing this saying
like I'm starting to doubt that he can
carry a show himself I found out it on
criticism because I don't doubt that
because they didn't let him carry it but
I I really wanted him to be front and
center I wanted him to be the main thing
except that I say that and at the same
time a lot of the stuff that focused on
Luke with some of the weaker stuff part
of that is the writing because like I
said he's being jerked around by the
plot and doesn't actually have a ton of
agency of his own but beyond that one it
focused on him it focused on weird
things like the the whole thing with his
father now I like the actor who who
played his father I like him a lot he
passed away recently which was
unfortunate but he doesn't do a lot to
the plot especially considering that you
know Luke keeps bringing up in a very
vague sense the whole Diamondback thing
from before but it's just something that
gets mentioned it doesn't actually pay
off in any meaningful way which
considering it was one of the things
that derailed the first season it this
was their opportunity to bring weight to
that and they kind of just didn't and
the whole thing with Luke like now he's
got anger management issues which that
kind of came out of nowhere and a lot a
lot of great characters get the short
shrift they can bundle off Claire after
a handful of episodes why colleen is
awesome her when she shows up and she
has her scenes with misty they're gone
I want these two to get a daughters of
the Dragon spin-off but she's there for
an episode and she's gone did
here's words I never thought I'd say
Danny Rand was good because his
chemistry and his rapport with Luke
these two actors are good and and to be
honest the actor who plays Danny seems
to have gotten better at the fight
scenes he seems to have gotten better at
selling the physicality and the fluidity
of it so that worked a little bit better
and there were some decent fight scenes
way too many of them were shot too dark
I don't know what these not look these
Marvel Netflix show have against
lighting fight scenes properly they're
always in either weird or dark lighting
and it's I know they think it's cool or
stylized it gets old and it gets old
dang quick yeah but uh you know what
misty she's a good character and she's
well acted I kind of feel like they
shouldn't have even been given her the
robot arm I say that like I know the
comics I know she gets one I was
expecting it but I found it way more
interesting when she was coping with
simply not having an arm like it's crazy
she gets in that fight she goes to to
swing with her right arm and nothing cuz
it's gone from here down like I was
diggin that but then when she gets the
robot arm it's not like super powerful
it's not like now she's got your extra
strong punching armor or anything like
that it's like she's got two arms again
and then it's like the fact that she
lost arm never comes up again it just
felt like a really hasty resolution to
something that they were getting decent
dramatic mileage of out of up to that
point and you know for all the
complaints I'm making in the season ends
in a really interesting place and what
it sets up to supposedly be the next
season in terms of where Luke is
especially could be really interesting
however the way they left things at
being first season leading into this one
also looked like they could have been
really interesting the I had really been
looking forward to seeing Mariah embrace
the criminal life and they just keep
having her on the back foot get cocky
and go crazy like that she didn't feel
like a threat because she she just never
felt like she had a grip on what was
going on and then bushmaster felt like a
threat but like is that he didn't really
care about Luke he was focused on Mariah
shades worked pretty well actually I
think in a lot of ways that he was
almost the emotional core of the story
maybe him and Tilda not like together
they didn't they had almost no scenes
together but like as characters I think
they for me at least they felt like the
emotional core of the story and I
mentioned before shades and Comanche
that scene and I like that that wasn't
just one scene in an earlier episode I
like that that that there was proper
weight and depth and meaning given to
that decision and actually I would call
it one of the better instances of of
LGBTQ representation in terms of the way
in which it's integrated into the story
because this is a case where his having
at least at some point in his life have
a same-sex relationship is not tossed
off as a oh by the way just so you know
this characters like that it's important
it's important to his relationships and
his function and the story and the way
he interacts with other characters it's
actually really well done and that's
gonna go on my list of good examples but
I just I keep coming back to the fact
that I I wish they could have named it
something other than Luke Cage and at
this point I would prefer if they hadn't
done the season two of Luke Cage and I'm
really not looking forward to a season
two of iron fist and they just done
Heroes for Hire pair the two of them
together because like I said they work
well together and inside you know it
almost feels like they came up with what
they wanted to do for season three and
then reverse engineered the stuff that
had to happen in order to allow for that
like okay well if we're gonna if we're
gonna have season three do this then we
got to be sure that Mariah gets taken
down how do we do that you know just get
miss your arm back and get her back on
the force how do we get all this and I
don't know I'm um I'm trying to figure
out how this panned out the way did it's
not bad it's not what I wanted which is
look I'll be completely honest it's kind
of a BS criticism because it's not
reflective of the quality of the piece
is reflective of my baggage and how it
how it met or failed to meet my hopes
and expectations but given that the name
of the show is Luke Cage I don't think
expecting him to be more central to be
that much of an out-there
expectation I don't know maybe I'm nuts
I'm sure folks will tell me if they
think I am so Luke Cage it's not bad
first second season it's certainly more
consistent then season one did cuz he's
the one took a nosedive halfway through
this didn't it just didn't really rise
up particularly high and it was it was
probably a few episodes too long there's
a lot of filler there's a lot of sort of
back foot and we spent a lot of time in
the same locations the the show started
to feel almost claustrophobic because
it's actually got a decent variety of
locations but for how
frequently we keep going back to the
club
the police warehouse the barbershop and
we just keep going to these places over
and over and over and over and over
again for scene after scene after scene
after scene it it made the show feel
small when the show was trying to branch
out and expand and feel bigger
but I don't know maybe I'm alone maybe
I'm nuts what were other people's
thoughts about Luke Cage did the fact
that Luke was not the central focus of
the story work for you were you
satisfied with the rest of what you got
did you actually feel that Luke was more
central to the thing that I'm giving him
credit for whatever your thoughts are
trumps let me down the commas let's talk
about it there's all the stuff to do so
just like and subscribe and buy a
t-shirt follow me on Twitter and all
sorts of other stuff all of which is
linked down in the description so until
next time this council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]